au sommaire la sortie du cirque de
mafate par le maïdo depuis roches plates
la curiosité de la semaine lille est de
roches plates pour cette randonnée dans
le cirque de mafate notre point de
rendez-vous et l'école de roches plates
situé en plein coeur de lille est
pour cette randonnée de difficulté
moyenne
longue de 8 km prévoir de bonnes
chaussures de quoi vous protéger de la
pluie et du froid et une réserve d'eau
pour votre santé
parcourez nos sentiers placés
stratégiquement entre les parties hautes
et basses de mafate roche plate et
l'inde et il est lé plus accessible du
cirque comme la nouvelle depuis le col
des boeufs roche plate satin rapidement
par le sentier qui descend du maïdo le
dénivelé étant beaucoup plus important
ce sentier s'adresse toutefois des
marcheurs plus entraîné que ce soit dans
le sens de la descente ou de la montée
l'option que nous avons choisi
aujourd'hui pour découvrir ce sentier
bordé de filao des eaux un bois très
utilisé par les habitants du cirque
la première partie du chemin monte
lentement jusqu'à la brèche de quoi
s'échauffer doucement tout en profitant
de beaux points de vue sur grand place
et sur le fond de la rivière des galets
sur les derniers mètres une main
courante conduit jusqu'à la brèche petit
col taillé dans la crête des orangers
qui sépare la ravine grand-mère du reste
du cirque un point de convergence de
plusieurs sentiers comme celui qui
remontent depuis lille est d orange est
idéal pour une petite pause avant
d'attaquer les choses sérieuses
pour rejoindre le col tout en haut il va
falloir en effet gravir un véritable mur
750 m de dénivelé sur un peu moins de 4
kilomètres même s'il s'agit de l'une des
voies d'accès au cirque les plus
vertigineuses ce sentier a pourtant été
historiquement l'un des plus empruntées
par les chasseurs de noir marron qui
faisait dès décembre dans mafate
descendre par ce sentier leur permettait
de dominer le cirque et d'y observer les
mouvements plutôt que d'être situé en
contrebas des islettes en passant par la
rivière des galets on raconte que cette
entrée était d'ailleurs l'une des plus
étroitement surveillés par les marrons
qui installé des postes de gay au sommet
du grand char au dessus de roches plates
lentement mais sûrement la montée ce
gravi à trois reprises des indications
peintes sur la roche permet de connaître
sa progression
salutaire pour certains mais
décourageante pour d'autres
ce la dernière partie la pente s'adoucit
le sentier s'éloigne de la crète pour
piquer droit vers le col à flanc de
falaise
il permet d'avoir de beaux points de vue
sur la ravine grand mère iliad et orange
et et le piton berrone
à 2020 9 mètres d'altitude nous voici
arrivés maintenant au col dit si
d'autres randonnées partant bord de
remparts il faudra descendre encore
quelques centaines de mètres sur de
larges dalles pour retrouver la route
forestière fin de notre randonnée
ce que j'aime sur cette randonnée c'est
sa difficulté déjà et puis ça donne sur
la falaise avec d'autres paysages mais
les oranje et j'adore de roches plates à
la brèche c'est plutôt dans les fils hao
et après de la brèche c'est vraiment vu
sur de l'autre côté de mafate vers les
orangers c'est beaucoup emprunté comme
itinéraire
comme passage porte d'entrée oui c'est
beaucoup moins quand il le fait dans la
journée c'est assez facile on peut le
faire en à leur tour même jusqu'à leur
choix tout voir les oranges et ses
conseillers à tout le monde mais il faut
quand même un minimum pratiquer un peu
de sport quand même parce que c'est une
montée assez difficile ce que j'aime pas
c'est la fin de sa nouveauté
au fait c'est l'eau et on a l'impression
qu'on a eu jamais au bout
panama
situé à l'aplomb du maïdo sur un vaste
plateau en demi-cercle roche plate est
positionné en plein coeur du cirque de
mafate
il a été divisé en deux parties la
première orientée nord-sud est situé en
dessous du rempart du grand bord est une
zone à risques naturels c'est le plateau
écoles la deuxième partie le plateau
église est orienté ouest est jusqu'au
bronchard moins exposés c'est dans cette
zone que lille est est amené à se
développer
comme dans la plupart des islettes
l'école et l'église sont les deux hauts
lieux de rassemblement construit dans
les années 50 l'école était l'une des
plus fréquentées du cirque avant que
celle des orangers ne soit ouvert
relativement isolé la chapelle est quant
à elle blotti entre les fils hao roches
plates fut aussi l'un des premiers
refuge des marrons en fuite notamment
pour ceux qui s'enfuyait de la côte
ouest
on raconte aussi que le sommet du
bronchard servait de lieu de
rassemblement des chefs marron